وقد نقلت صحيفه بوليتيكو عن مصادر مطلعه
قولها ان وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكل يستعد لزياره الصين خلال الاسبوع
المقبل وافادت الصحيفه ان وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه ما تزال تضع اللمسات الاخيره
لتفاصيل زياره بلنكن والتي ستكون الاولى
له منذ تعيينه في منصبه وكان بلينكن قد
اجل زيارته للصين خلال فبراير الماضي على
خلفيه تحليق منطاد صيني في الاجواء
الامريكيه حيث اتهمت واشنطن
استعمال هذا المنطاد لاغراض التجسس
من بجين تنضم الينا مراسلتنا شيماء هل
تطور الموقف او تغير بخصوص زياره بلينكن
هل تعلن السلطات الصينيه شيئا ما بخصوص
هذه الزياره المرتقبه الاسبوع المقبل
ليس الى حد الان مريم السلطات الصينيه لم
تعلن عن اي زياره مرتقبه او حتى عن اي
ترتيبات تجري بين الجانب الصيني والجانب
الامريكي فيما يتعلق بترتيب زياره وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انطونيو الى الصين
خلال الاسبوع المقبل والحقيقه مريم منذ
يوم الاربعاء الماضي كانت هنالك معطيات
شحيحه من قبل بعض وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
التي تحدثت عنه
الى الصين خلال الاسابيع المقبله حين ذلك
طرح السؤال على المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه وكان قد جاوب جوابا
مقتضبا جدا حول التهرب من السؤال وقال
بانه ليست هنالك اي معطيات بخصوص هذا
الشان اليوم تحديدا قال بانه ليس هنالك
معلومات بشان زياره بلنكن لكن تحدث عن
العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه وما تشهده من
توترات خلال الفتره الحاليه قال اليوم
خلال المؤتمر الصحفي بان على الجانب
الامريكي الا يقول ما لا يفعله على الارض
وقال الصين تحاول ان تبقي باب الحوار وباب
التواصل مفتوحا مع الجانب الامريكي لكن
على الجانب الامريكي ان يحترم كل المصالح
الصينيه وعليه ايضا الا يقوم بالاضرار
بمصالح الصين او ان يمس من سياده الصين
ووحده اراضيها هنا الاشاره مريم واضحه جدا
الى كل التوترات التي نشهدها على الارض
سواء عبر مضيق تايوان او في منطقه بحر
جنوب الصين خلال الايام الماضيه شاهدنا
امتعاضا شديدا وتصريحات شديده اللهجه من
الجانب الصيني ازاء التدريبات بحريه
ثلاثيه مشتركه بين طوكيو ومانيلا واشنطن
في منطقه بحر جنوب الصين الفلبين قالت بان
هذه التدريبات المشتركه لا تستهدف دوله
بعينها في المنطقه وبانها في مياهها
الاقليميه لكن الصين ترى بان هذه المياه
التي تتحدث عنها الفلبين والتي تجري فيها
المناورات العسكريه الثلاثيه المشتركه هي
مياه تابعه للصين بالتالي مريم هنالك
العديد من الملفات الشائكه والمعقده
والعالقه بين الجانب الصيني والجانب
الامريكي خاصه انه خلال الاونه الاخيره
ايضا كان هنالك لقاء مبرمج او مؤكد على
الاقل من الجانب الامريكي بين وزير الدفاع
الامريكي
في سنغافوره على هامش
مؤتمر شنغاريلا للامن الذي عقد هناك خلال
الاسبوع الماضي لكن الجانب الصيني رفض
رفضا تامن ان يتم هذا اللقاء واكد ايضا
على ان الصين تبقي باب الحوار مفتوحا بين
جيشي البلدين لكن هنالك معطيات او هنالك
حيثيات تقف دون تقف عائقا او تقف دون ان
يتم هذا اللقاء بين وزيري الدفاع البلدين
انذاك شاهدنا هذا اللقاء المقتضب جدا بين
وزير الدفاع سنغافوره انتهى فقط بمصافحه
سريعه جدا بين الجانبين والجانب الصيني
ايضا كان قد اشار الى ان وزير الدفاع
الصيني كان مازال يرزح تحت عقوبات من
الجانب الامريكي لذلك يستحيل هذا اللقاء
شيماء
شكرا جزيلا لك